Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: um wow that was allowed uh okay um so
Caption: yeah look I'm here to talk about web3
Caption: the great con
Caption: um uh look I yeah I'm the CTO and
Caption: co-founder at climate clever
Caption: um I love JavaScript
Caption: um all things JavaScript uh and have a
Caption: big bit of a passion for environment and
Caption: privacy
Caption: um I just obviously like to start by
Caption: acknowledging uh the traditional owners
Caption: of the land that were gathered on here
Caption: today and pay my respects to Elders past
Caption: present and emerging okay so I think
Caption: it's really really important to just set
Caption: the tone before I jump into this talk
Caption: because I've already had some
Caption: interesting
Caption: feedback so it's okay if you disagree
Caption: with the things that I say in this talk
Caption: we're allowed to disagree we don't all
Caption: have to think the same thing
Caption: however what I'm really going to be
Caption: talking about today is not really my
Caption: opinion although there's a little bit of
Caption: my opinion sprinkled in there most of
Caption: these are facts and issues that we
Caption: actually need to look at and they need
Caption: addressing we can't just ignore them
Caption: so yeah just keep that in mind we're
Caption: allowed to disagree if you want to come
Caption: talk to me later about stuff you're more
Caption: than welcome to but you won't be able to
Caption: change my mind hopefully I can change
Caption: yours
Caption: um but hey let's let's let's just um
Caption: let's have a quick look at what we're
Caption: going over today oh that was weird uh
Caption: that's why is it hang on a sec seems to
Caption: be
Caption: just
Caption: going itself so strange
Caption: let's let's try again Okay cool so
Caption: agenda so I'm going to give you a little
Caption: overview of blockchain crypto nft and
Caption: web3 uh we're going to talk about
Caption: ransomware uh energy use proof of stake
Caption: fraud decentralization censorship
Caption: privacy and we're going to end with the
Caption: financialization of everything now
Caption: that's a lot and these are all very deep
Caption: big topics that deserve their own talk
Caption: so we're going to dip into them a little
Caption: bit just so you can walk away with some
Caption: good knowledge
Caption: okay
Caption: so let's talk about blockchain what does
Caption: that even mean for those of you who
Caption: don't know so the best way to think
Caption: about it is a Excel sheet right so an
Caption: Excel sheet can sort of simulate a
Caption: blockchain and every row that's added to
Caption: that Excel sheet is like another Block
Caption: in the chain right so it's like a it's
Caption: like a ledger a digital Ledger and the
Caption: best way to also think about it is that
Caption: each row added in the Excel sheet or
Caption: each block added to the chain normally
Caption: refers to the block that came before it
Caption: and it does that using some form of
Caption: cryptography or cryptography always get
Caption: those two words mixed around okay and
Caption: another thing to think about is
Caption: transactions are normally irreversible
Caption: so if a block has been added to the
Caption: chain and you want to change it you
Caption: normally have to change every single
Caption: block that comes after it and that's
Caption: often referred to as forking the chain
Caption: so that's a very brief overview of what
Caption: blockchain is so let's talk about crypto
Caption: because that's probably the biggest use
Caption: of blockchain okay and where shall we
Caption: start we'll start with Bitcoin which is
Caption: the biggest and the original so uh for
Caption: those of you old enough to remember we
Caption: had the wonderful banking crisis in 2008
Caption: uh where the banks basically ripped us
Caption: all off and the governments failed to
Caption: regulate them properly so out of that
Caption: arose Bitcoin it was supposed to be an
Caption: end to centralize banking so
Caption: peer-to-peer currency and your crypto
Caption: wallet would work like a bank but the
Caption: biggest difference is that it would be
Caption: protected and safe against cash crises
Caption: like inflation or deflation that we
Caption: experience with centralized currency so
Caption: it was supposed to be you know this
Caption: thing that would liberate us all now
Caption: obviously its biggest and best probably
Caption: first use was uh Silk Road where you
Caption: could buy drugs online and get them in
Caption: the post a week later now uh Crypt
Caption: blockchain itself and Bitcoin at this
Caption: point were slow and expensive to use so
Caption: the trade-off for getting drugs in the
Caption: post with those High transaction fees
Caption: and slow transaction times was kind of
Caption: worth it
Caption: obviously Silk Road was eventually shut
Caption: down now Bitcoin also uses something
Caption: called proof of work to add blocks to
Caption: the chain
Caption: so in real simple terms
Caption: what that means is that the minor nodes
Caption: compete to solve an algorithm based on
Caption: the data inside the block and then it
Caption: gets added to the chain and that's
Caption: called proof of work but that Pro
Caption: process of you know Computing the data
Caption: in the algorithm is energy intensive and
Caption: that's why it's called proof of work
Caption: because you have to prove that you've
Caption: wasted some time and done some work and
Caption: we'll talk a bit more about that in a
Caption: bit
Caption: okay so let's talk about ethereum so
Caption: probably the second biggest crypto
Caption: blockchain thing after Bitcoin um so
Caption: it's created by vitalik butarian and
Caption: launched in 2014 there were other
Caption: co-founders
Caption: um involved as well it boasted lower
Caption: fees and faster transactional times and
Caption: the interesting about ethereum is it
Caption: could track blocks of data not just the
Caption: ethereum coin and these blocks of data
Caption: can be used to store programs often
Caption: um you know little bits of code whatever
Caption: whatever you can think of and vitalik
Caption: had a vision you know he envisioned a
Caption: future with the whole internet was
Caption: Rewritten where it was all decentralized
Caption: bypassing governments and Banks and
Caption: other centralized Services you know your
Caption: very identity could be stored on the
Caption: Chain
Caption: um a term that comes up a lot and we're
Caption: going to talk about it is banking the
Caption: young banked and the Forgotten which
Caption: personally I'm not too sure what that
Caption: actually means but we'll talk about it
Caption: okay so I've shared this quote from it's
Caption: doing that sorry I do apologize it's
Caption: doing that thing where it's like
Caption: skipping
Caption: slides
Caption: okay so I've shared this quote from
Caption: vitalik so I'll read it to you I cried
Caption: myself to sleep and on that day I
Caption: realized what Horrors centralized
Caption: Services can bring now that sounds
Caption: pretty drastic right so you'd think he'd
Caption: be talking about something absolutely
Caption: devastating but it turns out he's
Caption: talking about World of Warcraft so he
Caption: used to play World of Warcraft
Caption: and he logs on one day to find that his
Caption: favorite Mage wizard character's
Caption: favorite spell has been nerfed by the
Caption: dev team because the dev team thought it
Caption: was too effective and that was his
Caption: reaction and I haven't posted this to
Caption: make fun of him like we've all got way
Caption: attached to something in our lives I've
Caption: definitely got attached to video games
Caption: in the past but it's just I think it's
Caption: worth sharing because it's interesting
Caption: looking at the sort of thought process
Caption: that's happening inside the head of a
Caption: lot of the people working in the web 3
Caption: space
Caption: okay so nfts I'm pretty sure you've all
Caption: seen nfts over the last few years they
Caption: really exploded during covid
Caption: um or non-fungible tokens is their full
Caption: name it's a way of proving that
Caption: something is unique from a technical
Caption: perspective they're just this serial
Caption: number that can't be split into smaller
Caption: parts right so you know if you have two
Caption: nfts of the same thing they're going to
Caption: have different serial numbers so if you
Caption: took a picture of me right now away from
Caption: my arms and we turn that into an nft the
Caption: first one would have one serial number
Caption: the second one would have another serial
Caption: number and it's a bit like Prince of a
Caption: painting so you know when you have a
Caption: painting and you make prints the first
Caption: one is worth the most the second one a
Caption: little bit less and third and so on and
Caption: so forth now nfts
Caption: often referred to as tokens that
Caption: digitalize something can also store
Caption: small packets of data or code and these
Caption: are often referred to as smart contracts
Caption: now nfts are supposed to be a revolution
Caption: where they could liberate artists from
Caption: the gig economy they could be used for
Caption: identity tickets ownership and more
Caption: and I'm just going to once again just
Caption: step out of our little timeline here to
Caption: talk about another tweet from someone in
Caption: the nft space which I just find a little
Caption: confusing so nfts equal identity 2.0
Caption: can't remember the last time I used my
Caption: picture on the left and I'll read these
Caption: out to you emphasis on physical traits
Caption: genetic Lottery prone to bias and
Caption: Prejudice and then under his nft
Caption: identity by choice unique and digitally
Caption: scarce representation of values and
Caption: beliefs now I'm going to put aside the
Caption: fact that the nft looks like something
Caption: that we used to make in Ms pain at High
Caption: School
Caption: and the thing is Santiago has a vested
Caption: interest in you believing this is the
Caption: case because he paid the equivalent of a
Caption: hundred and seventy one thousand US
Caption: dollars for that nft on the right so
Caption: quite interesting
Caption: okay so last technical term and then
Caption: we're gonna delve into the
Caption: um the juicy bits um so web3 so web one
Caption: is like static content you know the web
Caption: in the early days where you would read
Caption: stuff you know on the internet you
Caption: didn't interact with it web 2 is users
Caption: creating content so like YouTube social
Caption: media we make videos we make posts you
Caption: know it's a much more service orientated
Caption: internet web3 is supposed to be this new
Caption: Revolution in the crypto space where
Caption: users control their data and content
Caption: things are more distributed and it's not
Caption: controlled by big corporations now the
Caption: thing is I actually agree with some of
Caption: that you know terminology being used
Caption: there I do believe we should all control
Caption: our own data and I also believe that
Caption: having all the power in a few tech
Caption: companies is a bad idea but I really
Caption: disagree with the execution
Caption: okay so time to spread some fud what's
Caption: fud Alex um so in the crypto space when
Caption: you spread negative thoughts or
Caption: sentiment or point out critical issues
Caption: in a project you often get accused of
Caption: spreading fud you know you're preventing
Caption: us all going to the moon and buying
Caption: Lambos or whatever they say so let's
Caption: spread some fud
Caption: okay let's talk about ransomware really
Caption: quickly ransomware is a terrible thing
Caption: right we are seeing schools hospitals
Caption: energy Supply pipelines being held to
Caption: Ransom by cyber criminals and most of
Caption: the time they have to pay in Bitcoin to
Caption: get their data back once it's been
Caption: stolen and encrypted we even have
Caption: individuals I mean I'm sure there's some
Caption: of you in this room with grandparents
Caption: that have had their data stolen and been
Caption: you know held at Ransom it happens all
Caption: the time and this is a 5.2 billion
Caption: dollar a year industry that is insane in
Caption: fact that number has probably gone up
Caption: since I made this slide
Caption: and it's worth pointing out that this
Caption: industry is only as big as it is because
Caption: of things like Bitcoin
Caption: because the thing is if you get held to
Caption: Ransom with your data and they say
Caption: transfer twenty thousand dollars to us
Caption: please if you go down to your bank to do
Caption: that online or in person they're going
Caption: to have questions about transferring
Caption: twenty thousand dollars they're not
Caption: going to just let you do it
Caption: and the thing is if they know that the
Caption: receiver is a known criminal or on their
Caption: sanctions list they're also not going to
Caption: do it the thing is by creating things
Caption: like Bitcoin we've actually created
Caption: loopholes around our centralized
Caption: Services allowing Industries like this
Caption: to flourish now look I'm not going to be
Caption: the first one to defend Banks they have
Caption: screwed us over a lot you know just look
Caption: at 2008 for example but the thing is
Caption: centralized Services exist for a reason
Caption: you know security sanctions and laws
Caption: need to be paid attention to and look
Caption: they're not always perfect but the thing
Caption: is we do have democratic governments so
Caption: we can try and get people elected that
Caption: make it better rather than creating
Caption: loopholes that create Industries as
Caption: predatory as this
Caption: so let's talk about energy and
Caption: environment possibly my favorite topic
Caption: because I work in the climate space now
Caption: we're going to talk about Bitcoin first
Caption: and for those of you who work in the
Caption: space don't worry we'll get to
Caption: environmentally friendly crypto coins as
Caption: well but we need to talk about Bitcoin
Caption: because it is the biggest and the worst
Caption: right so Bitcoin uses 0.5 of the world's
Caption: power just for Bitcoin that is a
Caption: tremendous amount of energy it uses more
Caption: energy annually than Argentina and then
Caption: the second factor that I think is really
Caption: really important it produces more
Caption: E-Waste than the Netherlands right so
Caption: Bitcoin is responsible for uh supply
Caption: shortages in chips ssds and more right
Caption: so when the PS5 came out and you
Caption: couldn't get one I mean obviously covet
Caption: played a part but it was also due to
Caption: bitcoin miners using all these chips
Caption: that's why people couldn't get a PS5 and
Caption: you know personally I don't want to live
Caption: in a world where you can't get a
Caption: PlayStation 5 when you want one
Caption: um
Caption: and there's something else to be said
Caption: now I'm not going to debate this climate
Caption: change is real if you don't believe this
Caption: then you can ignore this part of the
Caption: talk but we have to transition to
Caption: renewable energy in Australia I mean in
Caption: other countries they may have to use
Caption: nuclear but in other parts of the world
Caption: we've all got to transition right we
Caption: have to do it and there is only so much
Caption: energy in the world and one of my
Caption: arguments here is you really can't
Caption: afford to waste energy on a speculative
Caption: system like Bitcoin when we have to
Caption: transition to save our future and it's
Caption: also worth noting that only a few days
Caption: ago just as I was doing another practice
Caption: the White House tweeted that they are
Caption: actually looking at proof of work
Caption: blockchains and considering Banning them
Caption: because they're going to prevent them
Caption: from reaching reaching their
Caption: environmental targets and Bitcoin is
Caption: really bad so many dormant or near
Caption: dormant fossil fuel fired power plants
Caption: are restarted to mine Bitcoin a power
Caption: plant in New York increased its
Caption: emissions by six percent and heated up a
Caption: local Lake when they started mining
Caption: Bitcoin and we're seeing this all the
Caption: time there's so much green washing going
Caption: on we've got fossil fuel companies
Caption: bringing in Big Rigs of Bitcoin Miners
Caption: and attaching it to gas burn off to
Caption: power it we're making fossil fuel
Caption: companies more profitable
Caption: so you know inevitably people like Alex
Caption: keep talking about Bitcoin and which
Caption: uses proof of work which remember is
Caption: that complicated algorithm process to
Caption: add a block to a chain now there are
Caption: environmentally friendly
Caption: cryptocurrencies as well and they tend
Caption: to use thing called proof of stake so
Caption: it's more efficient because it doesn't
Caption: scale in cost and time like proof of
Caption: work but it does make participation
Caption: expensive so basically validation is
Caption: achieved by how much a user has to stake
Caption: so for example you need to hold a
Caption: certain amount of the crypto or tokens
Caption: to be able to add blocks to the chain so
Caption: that makes it really easy for someone
Caption: with a lot of money to own the entire
Caption: chain which begs the question is it
Caption: really decentralized then
Caption: um so it's not secure as proof of work
Caption: now ethereum currently uses proof of
Caption: work and is apparently going to be
Caption: switching to proof of stake for the last
Caption: seven years but they haven't however
Caption: they've made a big announcement this
Caption: month that they're finally going to do
Caption: it and it looks like they might actually
Caption: do it this time and that would make
Caption: ethereum environmentally friendly
Caption: however that's not where my beef ends
Caption: so let's talk about fraud and scams now
Caption: what I'm about to talk to you is all
Caption: facts and is a serious problem
Caption: 10.68 billion dollars has been lost to
Caption: scams or grifts since February 2021.
Caption: this is out of date I made this slide
Caption: two weeks ago it has gone up since then
Caption: so let's have a look at the scams that
Caption: happen so rug pools these are really
Caption: common so it's where a developer uh or
Caption: you know a company raises tokens and
Caption: then makes a run for the door with
Caption: Investments right so a good way to think
Caption: about this you know a startup you have
Caption: an idea you build an MVP you raise
Caption: investment you build the product you
Caption: grow the value of the company well in
Caption: the web 3 space what happens a lot of
Caption: the time is that you know people have
Caption: vague plans for a video game or a
Caption: product or something and then they raise
Caption: all these tokens and then they just cash
Caption: out and disappear and they shut down all
Caption: the social media sites they shut down
Caption: the website I mean this one this one's
Caption: fantastic air Moon rug pulls for 6.3
Caption: million dollars I mean besides being a
Caption: blatant poke come on riff path like
Caption: it's just all my favorite one Martin the
Caption: wonderful pharmaceutical guy from
Caption: America who jacked up the price of a
Caption: much needed drug once he got out of
Caption: prison he started his own nft project
Caption: and got hacked and all the money
Caption: disappeared very interesting or this one
Caption: bribe protocol team disappears after
Caption: raising 5.5 million dollars I mean one
Caption: the amount of money that they raise is
Caption: insane but the fact that he just
Caption: disappear and most of the time get away
Caption: with it is really bad
Caption: now let's talk about lies because this
Caption: happens a lot and I think it's really
Caption: worth addressing
Caption: so
Caption: Celsius network is like a Bank savings
Caption: account except the idea is you put your
Caption: crypto in it so if I have some Bitcoin
Caption: or ethereum I can lend it to Celsius in
Caption: like their account and they loan it out
Caption: to other people and I earn interest on
Caption: my crypto being with them now it was
Caption: touted as being safer than a bank you
Caption: know the new type of Investments but in
Caption: the crypto crash this year they
Caption: suspended all withdrawals and swaps in
Caption: June and then in July they filed for
Caption: bankruptcy now they've been accused of
Caption: being a Ponzi scheme but during their
Caption: bankruptcy hearings people have written
Caption: in to explain the losses that they've
Caption: suffered now I've stayed up late at
Caption: night reading some of these and they are
Caption: brutal right they are absolutely
Caption: devastating some of them talk about
Caption: suicide and really dark things now I've
Caption: filtered out some of the darkest ones
Caption: but I've included three that I want to
Caption: read to you because I feel it's
Caption: important to understand the position
Caption: so my name is Brandon Lawrence I'm
Caption: writing the letter for the same reason
Caption: as many I am one of the little guys I
Caption: put my life savings and Trust into
Caption: Celsius and Co even worse I took out a
Caption: margin loan on Robinhood for 50 grand
Caption: for a Bitcoin and it's near high and I
Caption: sent it to Celsius to offset the monthly
Caption: margin interest I also sent a Bitcoin
Caption: from when I was buying a little bit here
Caption: and there around 2018 and up it was my
Caption: Nest Egg now when I go to work I drink
Caption: water eat any scraps I can find for
Caption: lunch every day I'm still paying for the
Caption: Bitcoin I do not have with interest I'm
Caption: in deep depression and do not know if I
Caption: can pull myself out of this
Caption: here's another one for you both my wife
Caption: and I are depositors in Celsius and have
Caption: three young boys aged 11 17 and 20. we
Caption: are unaccredited USA investors and will
Caption: learn to Celsius based on promises
Caption: directly from the CEO that our deposits
Caption: are safe and can be withdrawn at any
Caption: time the CEO of Celsius stated several
Caption: times that Celsius is safer and better
Caption: than a bank and those sentiments were
Caption: reflected in their advertising
Caption: now there is one more and just to give
Caption: you warning there is a mention of
Caption: domestic violence uh just to let you
Caption: know
Caption: um just for any of those who might be
Caption: triggered by past experiences
Caption: during my life I've escaped domestic
Caption: abuse perpetrated within a 28-year
Caption: marriage raised an orphan as an older
Caption: adult without any support I've survived
Caption: a brain tumor while coping with
Caption: polycystic kidney disease debilitating
Caption: arthritis and extreme fibromyalgia
Caption: during the years of raising my son as a
Caption: single mother I scrimped and saved for
Caption: Amiga retirement regretfully I placed 70
Caption: of my funds in an earned account in the
Caption: Celsius Network now as a single senior
Caption: citizen I face kidney dialysis
Caption: additionally I'll be forced to sell my
Caption: home return to work and possibly rely on
Caption: government relief to make up for this
Caption: deception
Caption: now I know that some of you in this room
Caption: will be thinking hey you should only
Caption: invest what you can afford to lose
Caption: and I think it's really really important
Caption: to hear to point out that that is victim
Caption: blaming Celsius lied to these people
Caption: they defrauded them they sold them false
Caption: promises they told them things were safe
Caption: and their money was in good hands they
Caption: were lied to so if this pops into your
Caption: head please just throw it away because
Caption: it's an invalid argument it is victim
Caption: blaming and I think another thing to
Caption: think about here is we live in a society
Caption: which isn't fair there are systems that
Caption: when you end up in poverty keep you down
Caption: and the chances are most of you in this
Caption: room might never have experienced
Caption: poverty we work in Tech which gives us
Caption: access to a relatively good lifestyle
Caption: but the thing is when you're in poverty
Caption: all you can do is think about how am I
Caption: going to get out of this where's my next
Caption: meal going to come from and when someone
Caption: comes along promising the world and
Caption: saying to you I've got the solution
Caption: that's going to break you out of the
Caption: system that's going to stop you from
Caption: being poor you're going to take that
Caption: because you're looking for that Ray of
Caption: Hope
Caption: so I really hate this whole sentiment
Caption: that you should only invest what you can
Caption: afford to lose especially when the
Caption: company is selling the future are lying
Caption: so yeah look there's more scams inside
Caption: of trading so staff at coinbase have
Caption: been accused of buying tokens before
Caption: they list so coinbase is a platform
Caption: where you can buy and sell
Caption: cryptocurrency uh Ponzi schemes endless
Caption: projects returning profits from new
Caption: investors to Old investors whilst
Caption: trading so that's kind of like where
Caption: multiple accounts all by the same or
Caption: multiple people sell nfts between them
Caption: to inflate the price by the way all of
Caption: this stuff that I've just mentioned
Caption: with normal security so like stocks and
Caption: bonds and companies it's against the law
Caption: if you do insider trading wash trading
Caption: you go to jail there is a whole
Caption: regulation industry set up to prevent it
Caption: and look it doesn't always work but it's
Caption: illegal and the thing is this industry
Caption: doesn't have any laws to protect it to
Caption: protect normal everyday people now we
Caption: are starting to see some punishments in
Caption: America and other places but so many
Caption: people are still getting away with all
Caption: these terrible things we also have
Caption: copyright issues artists who were
Caption: supposed to be liberated by nfts getting
Caption: angry when their work is stolen and
Caption: minted and sold as an nft without their
Caption: permission and I think my favorite part
Caption: about this is when they go to complain
Caption: they get laughed at or chastised saying
Caption: it's their fault for not doing it sooner
Caption: and being part of the future you know
Caption: theft because in crypto you know we're
Caption: not using Banks you're supposed to be
Caption: your own bank it's so easy to scam and
Caption: fraud people dropping nfts into people's
Caption: wallets that when they click it drains
Caption: out all their money
Caption: now I could really go on about all these
Caption: but one I'll be having a classic
Caption: Alexander rant and two it does get quite
Caption: depressing but I think it's worth
Caption: mentioning here that crypto is zero sum
Caption: by Design now what does that even mean
Caption: um I have to admit when someone first
Caption: explained it to me I was like what but
Caption: the best way to think about like this
Caption: when you buy a stock in a company
Caption: the company generates value because it
Caption: sells a service so it develops a product
Caption: so more people become interested in it
Caption: more people buy it so the value grows
Caption: right so you get value because it's
Caption: generated value in crypto that's not how
Caption: it works right blockchain doesn't and
Caption: Bitcoin don't generate value not making
Caption: anything so your only chance to make
Caption: money is to buy low sell high but
Caption: because it isn't generating value when
Caption: you sell at a high than when you brought
Caption: you need someone else to put money in
Caption: for you to get out which means it's zero
Caption: sum because for you to take money out
Caption: someone has to put money in but when you
Caption: take into consideration Miners and
Caption: exchanges that extract money from the
Caption: system it makes it strictly negative
Caption: some which is really weird because we
Caption: now have this system where we've got all
Caption: these fraud and scams it's zero sum by
Caption: design it almost sounds like a
Caption: multi-level marketing scheme and this
Caption: kind of gets backed up by these
Caption: wonderful celebrities here doing all
Caption: these wonderful crypto ads for those of
Caption: you who've not seen it Matt Damon's ad
Caption: where he Compares investing in crypto to
Caption: landing on the moon and basically causes
Caption: all cowards for not investing has to be
Caption: the worst advert I've ever seen or the
Caption: Larry Super Bowl ad Don't Be Like Larry
Caption: start investing today or Paris Hilton on
Caption: late night talking about their nfts
Caption: because this is the thing it doesn't
Caption: generate value so to keep money coming
Caption: in they have to keep the hype train
Caption: going otherwise it stops
Caption: so let's explore this decentralized uh
Caption: things we're going to shift Lanes a
Caption: little bit here so we've talked about
Caption: the fraud and scams and things but let's
Caption: talk about decentralized so that's
Caption: that's one of the big touts that it's
Caption: decentralized we own it it's not owned
Caption: by people but most of the major services
Caption: in the web 3 space are run on
Caption: centralized servers and just query the
Caption: blockchain with an API if a miner owns
Caption: 51 of a network is it really
Caption: decentralized
Caption: and these are things that are all worth
Caption: thinking if you have to have a bank
Caption: account and go through a centralized
Caption: exchange to use a web 3 app
Caption: is it decentralized I have to admit I
Caption: set up a metamask wallet myself and it
Caption: took me about half an hour and I'm a
Caption: developer so God knows how we're going
Caption: to get normal people to do it
Caption: so that's
Caption: actually here sort of helps move my
Caption: decentralized argument so Moxie is one
Caption: of the founders of signals so he created
Caption: this nft if you want to go figure out
Caption: how he did it it's up on his Twitter but
Caption: basically it looked different based on
Caption: where you viewed it so if you viewed it
Caption: on openc one of the biggest centralized
Caption: platforms for buying and selling nfts it
Caption: looked one way and if you looked at it
Caption: on variable another but if you looked at
Caption: it in your crypto wallet it rendered out
Caption: as a poo Emoji which is just absolutely
Caption: fantastic
Caption: but this is funny he was delisted from
Caption: Open Sea for violating their terms and
Caption: conditions but I thought it was a
Caption: censorship-free decentralized system but
Caption: it gets even better then his crypto
Caption: wallet stopped showing the nft because
Caption: it turns out his crypto wallet just
Caption: queried Open Seas API to check for the
Caption: nft's Existence so none of that is
Caption: decentralized that's all using
Caption: centralized services
Caption: so let's dig into censorship resistance
Caption: a little bit now I want to start by
Caption: saying I am a firm believer in freedom
Caption: of speech you have the right to say
Caption: whatever you want and I think that
Caption: should be right and it's very depressing
Caption: in other countries where governments use
Caption: their power to suppress that but the
Caption: thing is freedom of speech does not give
Caption: you freedom of consequences and also
Caption: using your freedom of speech to suppress
Caption: other people's freedom of speech is
Caption: plain wrong and I think we need to talk
Caption: about this censorship resistant
Caption: blockchain because the thing is there is
Caption: stuff out there that needs censoring
Caption: right since content moderators that work
Caption: for YouTube Facebook and Twitter they
Caption: don't last very long in their jobs
Caption: censoring the content that gets uploaded
Caption: and they see the worst of humanity there
Caption: are some dark places in our society
Caption: child porn animal violence this stuff is
Caption: real and it happens all the time and
Caption: needs to be censored if we create a cent
Caption: censorship resistant complete system we
Caption: are going to allow child pornography
Caption: hate racism to just spew out all online
Caption: which isn't really a great place
Caption: and let's expand on that a little bit
Caption: and talk about the death of privacy so
Caption: I'm a big privacy Advocate I go out of
Caption: my way at the startup I work at to try
Caption: and respect privacy as much as possible
Caption: even building analytics in a different
Caption: way all that sort of stuff and privacy
Caption: is important and blockchain often gets
Caption: touted as it's more secure it's the data
Caption: in your hands and look we should have
Caption: data in our hands I agree with that but
Caption: the thing is it's not really private
Caption: because I cannot stress this enough it's
Caption: a public Ledger everything you do is
Caption: visible to the public now if you don't
Caption: connect that identity to anything in the
Caption: real world sure it gives you the ability
Caption: to harass and annoy and disappear right
Caption: but the second you start connecting it
Caption: to anything in the real world or someone
Caption: figures out that that wallet belongs to
Caption: you everything you do is going to be
Caption: available for everyone to see we're
Caption: talking privacy violations way worse
Caption: than Google and Facebook have ever
Caption: committed it especially when you've got
Caption: things like this I
Caption: ethereum co-founder says we'll soon use
Caption: Soul bound tokens to verify things like
Caption: school and employment all stored in a
Caption: Soul's wallet I don't even know what any
Caption: of that means
Caption: but the thing is once we start attaching
Caption: things like that to the blockchain
Caption: that's there forever because remember it
Caption: can't be deleted even if it's fought it
Caption: can still be found you know accidentally
Caption: take a photo with your credit card in
Caption: the background that's up there forever
Caption: somebody uploads Revenge point of view
Caption: that's up there forever it's never going
Caption: away and I think there's another thing
Caption: worth mentioning is that most of the
Caption: people working in this space are
Caption: straight white men like me and we don't
Caption: experience harassment stalking in the
Caption: same way that people of color or women
Caption: do we just don't and the thing is that
Caption: stuff will become easier to do like I
Caption: said privacy will disappear
Caption: so we're running short on time because
Caption: we start a little bit late so let's just
Caption: just cool off a little bit Alex and
Caption: we'll go into financialization of
Caption: everything
Caption: um so so one of the end goals of the web
Caption: three space right is that everything is
Caption: on the Chain everything you do is on the
Caption: chamber incentivized for our time with
Caption: earning tokens uh you pay for everything
Caption: on the chain and I think one real good
Caption: example of this is axi infinity which is
Caption: a video game using nfts and blockchains
Caption: it's pretty much just Pokemon it's
Caption: Pokemon with nfts
Caption: um so the way it works is you buy a rent
Caption: three nfts called axes
Caption: um and then you battle them and you earn
Caption: tokens for battling and you use those
Caption: tokens to breed more axes or you can
Caption: cash out for real money
Caption: um now it's very expensive to get
Caption: started like when it first started it
Caption: was very low it can it cost a few
Caption: hundred dollars at least to set up one
Caption: team one thing you can do is set up a
Caption: bunch of teams and rent them out to
Caption: people and then you earn fifty percent
Caption: of whatever they're doing now they've
Caption: got a lot of good press
Caption: about how they help people in the
Caption: Philippines earn money you know it's
Caption: like hey these people are now earning
Caption: money you know playing a video game but
Caption: the thing is play to earn is not play to
Caption: have fun so when we had the crypto crash
Caption: earlier this year they saw their player
Caption: numbers drop massively because people
Caption: were just using it to earn money they
Caption: were just grinding to earn money and
Caption: when you take into consideration there's
Caption: lots of whales so that's people with
Caption: lots of money renting out nfts earning
Caption: 50 of the money they're earning it
Caption: almost sounds a bit like a sweat Factory
Caption: but let's let's let's investigate that
Caption: good press on how many people in the
Caption: Philippines make money earning you know
Caption: earning playing the game only 23 of
Caption: adults in the Philippines have a bank
Caption: account right so remember you need a
Caption: bank account to buy crypto and play
Caption: crypto and work with crypto so how many
Caption: people are we actually helping I feel
Caption: that's one of the things that we do in
Caption: Tech a lot it's like this solves this
Caption: problem we should do it but we never
Caption: actually talk to the people we say we're
Caption: helping you know and I think a example
Caption: outside of the web 3 space and you might
Caption: hate me for this and this is okay is
Caption: Elon Musk satellite system for internet
Caption: right like he's like oh we're bringing
Caption: internet to people in the regions have
Caption: we asked them what they want is internet
Caption: top of their list I'm pretty sure that
Caption: if you talk to most people living in the
Caption: regions they'd be like uh 24-hour access
Caption: to doctors and nurses more public
Caption: services and infrastructure that isn't
Caption: falling apart and 50 years old you know
Caption: not saying the Internet isn't important
Caption: but it's one of those things where like
Caption: let's just shove a whole bunch of
Caption: satellites in the atmosphere every year
Caption: and not think about the consequences
Caption: because apparently we're doing doing
Caption: some good
Caption: and in the end it's people that lose
Caption: right like it's people that get left out
Caption: it's people that suffer the consequences
Caption: of us just charging ahead and doing
Caption: something I think not a week goes by
Caption: where people aren't like oh let's stick
Caption: this on the blockchain for example let's
Caption: put power distribution and on the
Caption: blockchain that will make things better
Caption: but then who decides when we disconnect
Caption: someone when they're struggling with
Caption: finances who decides that we keep
Caption: someone connected to the power because
Caption: they've got medical devices if we create
Caption: this decentralized system a really good
Caption: example is if you take Synergy or
Caption: state-owned power company and you
Caption: compare it that to all the private
Caption: companies over East which is a little
Caption: bit like a blockchain they've all don't
Caption: really work together that well they all
Caption: do whatever they want our disconnection
Caption: rate
Caption: our disconnection rate in wa for people
Caption: in financial hardship is much lower
Caption: because we have a centralized system
Caption: working together
Caption: you know look at Myspace the environment
Caption: space everyone's like oh if we put
Caption: offsets on the blockchain it fixes them
Caption: you know we need carbon offsets to
Caption: offset some emissions that are
Caption: unavoidable but the thing is the
Caption: industry is Rife with lies fraud kicking
Caption: people off their own land in third world
Caption: countries and the thing is how does
Caption: sticking that on the blockchain fix it
Caption: one it doesn't stop people lying before
Caption: they put data in there and all it does
Caption: is create another Financial Market on
Caption: top of the other
Caption: and I think that's the biggest thing
Caption: that I want you guys to take away from
Caption: this is that Tech alone isn't going to
Caption: save us we have to actually trust each
Caption: other and work together and stop just
Caption: pushing ahead with tech because it seems
Caption: cool or fun
Caption: so please just remember we can trust
Caption: each other we can work together and
Caption: centralized systems are important too
Caption: I'd like to thank some of these amazing
Caption: people that I got some of the content
Caption: for this talk from because I feel like
Caption: although I read and work in this space a
Caption: bit these people are far more
Caption: experienced than I am Molly Y in
Caption: particular is probably the coolest
Caption: person you could ever meet and kicking
Caption: ass and documenting some of the terrible
Caption: things happening in this space
Caption: and I'd also like to thank our sponsors
Caption: uh for today at DD Perth thank you very
Caption: much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you Alex
Caption: um we've got about five minutes before
Caption: there's morning tea in all the foyers
Caption: the next session is starting at 11 25 so
Caption: is there anyone who's got a question for
Caption: Alex before we wrap up
Caption: cool oh dear
Caption: so the hype Train's real how do we get
Caption: investors in startups to avoid throwing
Caption: cash at shiny things that have web3 and
Caption: crypto in them oh see so that's a
Caption: difficult question right and I don't
Caption: have a perfect answer for that
Caption: um because I work for a startup too and
Caption: I've seen other companies just come
Caption: along with a wild idea get millions of
Caption: dollars and we only ever got a few
Caption: hundred thousand to start with so I
Caption: think I think there's that thing where
Caption: it's like you have to look at is endless
Caption: growth always a good thing can I
Caption: bootstrap a startup with income first
Caption: before I go to investors and just try
Caption: and avoid those investors which means
Caption: less stuff will be built that doesn't
Caption: have web 3 but hey maybe we have a
Caption: slightly better Society for it as well
Caption: too
Caption: or Samantha any other questions
Caption: yeah just be curious in your opinion on
Caption: whether there exists maybe a possibility
Caption: for some sort of decentralized financial
Caption: product for example I'm thinking of the
Caption: problems on the internet with a
Caption: MasterCard and Visa strangle on certain
Caption: services and yeah so I do have an answer
Caption: for this and some of you might not like
Caption: it so
Caption: I agree things like internet and payment
Caption: actually internet infrastructure not
Caption: just payment infrastructure is a
Caption: necessary for today's world right just
Caption: like electricity and water and necessity
Caption: so maybe it's time that certain
Caption: infrastructure isn't actually owned by
Caption: private companies anymore but actually a
Caption: public owned good now look yeah
Caption: governments have some bad reputations
Caption: for running things but the thing is
Caption: maybe that's actually what starts the
Caption: need to happen maybe we need a publicly
Caption: owned payment infrastructure maybe we
Caption: need publicly owned infinite internet
Caption: internet and server infrastructure
Caption: because the thing is we actually need it
Caption: to function and maybe it's time we
Caption: modernize our governments a little bit
Caption: to make that possible
Caption: thank you fantastic uh any other
Caption: questions down front
Caption: um I was just going to ask so obviously
Caption: in the late 90s we had the the.com
Caption: bubble where a bunch of companies went
Caption: on the internet and they didn't have to
Caption: and everything just kind of went
Caption: straight down downhill from there yeah
Caption: but obviously the underlying technology
Caption: was somewhat useful in the modern world
Caption: so do you feel the whole system of web 3
Caption: as a whole is completely useless or is
Caption: it more that it's kind of the wild wild
Caption: rest right now I personally I agree that
Caption: it is useless but that's my personal
Caption: opinion and I I disagree with the Wild
Caption: Wild West because although there was a
Caption: bit of Wawa West when the.com bubble
Caption: happened there wasn't this level of
Caption: Fraud and scams right that's that's this
Caption: is insane like if this was happening in
Caption: the banking industry on a daily basis it
Caption: would be on the news every night right
Caption: like it's and and the thing is look
Caption: maybe there is a use for blockchain that
Caption: I'm not aware of right that we could
Caption: actually do but technically don't we
Caption: already have that and I think it's
Caption: called get you know like it's uh like
Caption: maybe we already found the use case
Caption: um look I just I just want people to to
Caption: be protected so you know really I think
Caption: the industry should be regulated and I
Caption: think you'd find if that happened it
Caption: would probably mostly disappear because
Caption: like I said it's zero-sum by Design
Caption: awesome uh one last question over here
Caption: so you talked about uh public ownership
Caption: or government ownership is there any
Caption: initiatives like that
Caption: they've started or are they thinking
Caption: about it no no there isn't which sucks
Caption: right I mean there are some people in
Caption: America talking about it
Caption: um but I think that's actually what
Caption: needs to happen right we need to stop
Caption: saying oh you know government's terrible
Caption: at running this well let's make a
Caption: government good at running this right I
Caption: know people push for privatization of
Caption: synergy and look we're delving into my
Caption: personal beliefs a little bit here but
Caption: that's okay and you're allowed to
Caption: disagree with me but I believe our
Caption: energy should be stay owned you know it
Caption: kept our power prices lower most of the
Caption: time it leads to better things this
Caption: whole thing of choice in certain things
Caption: is important but when it's
Caption: infrastructure so really maybe working
Caption: in the tech space we should all start
Caption: pushing for that because it is needed
Caption: awesome and uh can we give another round
Caption: of applause to Alexander thank you thank
Caption: you
Caption: he's going to be kidnapped briefly for a
Caption: photo of all our speakers but after that
Caption: he will be in the foyer and I'm sure you
Caption: can track him down for any other
Caption: questions thank you for joining us